this Patriots rookie kicker Justin wore
Wasser he has this tattoo and it has the
number three and some stars and stripes
on that and this refers to this idea
that only 3% of Americans in the
Revolutionary War fought for the
Patriots side and the rest r either
neutral or they supported the British or
they wouldn't actually put their money
where their mouth is and stand up
against British tyranny this is an idea
that's got long standing in American
history and then this idea of the 3%
came up during the Tea Party movement
over the last 10 12 years or so so this
rookie kickers got that little tattoo on
and now the American culture is trying
to shame him tell him that that's
actually racist and bigoted and evil and
terrible and awful if he identifies with
the American Revolution so he was
brought on a local news program and he
was basically just bullied into removing
the tattoo here's Row Wasser on Twitter
and I I saw the tweet I saw that someone
had taken a picture of me and put it
with you know my tattoo and linking me
to some horrific events you know
obviously Charlottesville and these
horrible things no no never
it was you know the first time I found
out what it was linked to was on on
Saturday and that's that's why I was you
know so that's that's why it was so
surprising did you get well when I was
18 I got it and it is described to me as
you know the percentage of colonists
that rose up against the authority of
the British wow that's such a you know
American sentiment a patriotic sentiment
and I'm coming from a military family
yeah I thought that really spoke to me
and I you know I I always was proud to
be in America I'm very proud ah that's
the problem you're not allowed to have
any
a feeling of loyalty of your country
anymore that's the problem listen to the
way this is being framed same wool did
you know that you're actually a racist
neo-nazi skinhead all right fascist
terrible person when you got that tattoo
and the guy goes no didn't know that I
thought it was the American Revolution
and the three-percent the foot the
British and I love my country and I've
got a lot of military members in my
country and I'm not a bad guy what I'm
not allowed to support the American
Revolution anymore and no you're not the
way they link it they're talking about
all these awful bigots and people and
events well I did a little look into the
three-percent thing I mean it's a
totally disparate group of people so
it's you know people can wear it not
even know that there are any
organizations called the three-percent
but I said okay maybe look maybe the
three-percent organization is actually a
bigoted terrible hate group well I
looked into it and after Charlotte's
ville you know after the alt-right rally
at Charlotte's ville there was a group
of the three-percent people which is the
National Council and they said
explicitly we will not align ourselves
with any type of racist group for the
you know if one or two people who have
the 3% tattoo showed up to this thing
they shouldn't do it don't do it we
don't support this we disavow it and yet
this guy is being shamed for it
it's a strange culture I mean now that
wouldn't have happened fifty years ago
if you said 50 years ago yeah I really
support the American Revolution you
would not have been shamed out of
football but now football is an is an
anti-american activity right we now have
league wide protests of the American
flag
not just league wide protests of the
cops not just league wide protests of
the military not just league wide
protests of Donald Trump league wide
protests of the American flag which is
the symbol of the country itself in our
sporting events and sports are always
patriotic that is in the nature of games
of sports something has gone terribly
wrong here